so league of legends
yes what about i'm just gonna drown
myself real quick what about it so joey
have you heard of this uh new anime or
animated series um called arcane as the
league of
okay so at the time of recording only
the first three episodes are out so it
might have been a massive failure after
the next six came out yeah so we don't
know but the first three episodes
it looks and was really [ __ ] good
like it's
really it looks good yeah the visuals
are insane it is genuinely like i i came
into this because i i you know me and
kind of both play league you know we
earth toxic yeah we're both very toxic
gamers in that sense and every time we
talk about league joey just like just
like conks out
um so what i was expecting was just a
mediocre video game fantastic
yeah fan services adaptation i just
wanted some cool fight scenes basically
just like an extended version of the
league cinematics you know what i mean
and i would have been happy but uh like
i watched the first three episodes and i
was just so unprepared for what i think
is like
one of like so this is just watching
three episodes it's legitimately like
the best three episodes of like any show
i've watched this year i i can't think
of like a show that just has a stronger
start i agree it was like oh my god like
it
the visuals are like pixar level of like
detail at times yeah yeah into a like a
nine episode show yeah i just don't
understand how they're doing it like the
animation is insane yeah joey look i
know you've like quit anime and
everything like that but but i i swear
to god this is something that even if
you have zero interest in league it
literally doesn't matter even if you
[ __ ] even if you [ __ ] hate league
you don't you don't you need zero
[ __ ] knowledge about the game because
it's all about what i love that it
focuses on like the character and worlds
um because what this what this series
made me realize is that league actually
has a really [ __ ] interesting world
and that's what really drew me in which
was there was so much thought that was
put into the world building and the law
which is like
league law was like the meme for a long
time it was a mess because you kept
rewriting it because they would
introduce characters and that oh no so
they had like this mess of like
characters that people really like with
really interesting backstories
but they didn't really know how to like
connect it and then they just literally
at one point just gave up yeah they just
stopped doing it yeah they're like
no one's reading it they should do like
articles all the time do you remember
and no one read it
because it was a mess because it like
made like no i mean it did make sense
but it was just so confusing and hard to
digest that the only way people consumed
it was through youtube videos of people
explaining it yeah i think most players
didn't really care to begin with right
now yeah exactly they're like no one's
playing league for the law no no
it's like how many how many like curse
words can you take per minute instead of
how many how many how many character
laws do you know you know it's different
but like i i think you would enjoy it if
you give it a shot sherry uh it's it's
it's not like league at all really
really not
the only benefit you get of being a
league fan is that your character's
names come up while you're like oh i
know that character yeah but then in the
show they're like nothing like the
character no no so it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter it doesn't matter because
a lot of the times you're guessing it's
like is that is that that character is
that that champion but most of the time
they're just characters in their show
which is which is what i like right they
don't they don't like fan service
certain characters because they are
characters in the show a lot of the
times there there is just this world
that exists and some people in these and
some people in this world happen to be
lead characters and that's it's a show
where i feel like it just
it it
you don't have to be a league fan to
enjoy it and it prevails
with like mass marketing league as a
franchise as opposed to just the game
and
it's like honestly the only video game
adaptation i think that even like stands
close to it is castlevania it's like
castlevania level of like
like video game adaptations i just have
to see where the next six episodes go
but like right now god damn god damn
very impressed it was interesting
watching watching a show like this with
a twitch chat though because yeah yeah
you'd have these like really really
serious moments going on and then you'd
watch twitch chat and everyone's just
like jungle feeding me jungle feeder
it's like
afk adc fk and i'm just like okay okay
it's pretty fun without the same time is
it ruining my viewing experience i'm not
quite sure
it was like genuinely like a
movie quality experience watching this
thing yeah like in a tv series like
everything was so on point like the
sound design was insane the animation
especially i i could go on and on about
how good the animation is and the voice
acting is really good like everything so
far has been good like yeah absolute
bangers like i know like the meme is you
know lol netflix anime netflix live
action adaptation but man netflix video
game adaptations are [ __ ] knocking it
out the park man so far so far so far so
far again i'm really hoping that this
doesn't age poorly and yeah i'm really
i'm really hoping but like because like
the episodes like as well like you you
know at one point i thought oh we're
getting a predictable story and then it
just kind of like flips you on its head
yeah i was like oh
oh [ __ ] okay
what about oh jesus
that's really good really really good
yeah like what other video game
adaptations have they done because i
know pennsylvania so far right
castlevania netflix yeah
netflix had an anime
it wasn't it wasn't good okay well dude
is a bad game too
so
well
done a fans of seething right yeah
yeah
i watched a little bit of the darter
anime and it wasn't good why just
because i was curious you should watch
the league out of me because you're
curious i'll add it to my watchlist
please i i've never wanted you to watch
an anime more than this just watch it
later please it's good you know you know
joey i i actually would prefer to you
like for you to watch league animation
than to watch any anime this year
it's actually good please give it a shot
it's actually so good be sure to check
it out
getting this guy to watch anime is like
[ __ ] impossible
he refuses to watch an anime
i guess i guess it settles it though you
know league better than dodo right
checkmate
well one thing that league has always
been good at was making anything but
league game gameplay like anything that
wasn't the game they were amazing at
making like every single animation thing
we got was insane yeah all the time [ __ ]
was [ __ ] dude yeah i think about the
[ __ ] everything they've made outside
of league is amazing like
in terms of aside from the game i
remember when kda first came out and i'm
just like what the [ __ ] league is cool
now yeah and i'm like that lasted for a
week and it was like the most surreal
week ever everyone
it was like the one week where like fake
league fans came out where it was like
cool to play league and then and then
now it's narrative yeah now has gone
back you know
yeah yeah no amount of hot k-pop girls
can get people to play that game
to be fair that kda [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
inescapable though it was yeah when i
watched it i was like wait do i like
kpop
right
yeah i don't play it anymore you're not
a big deal and kda came out and he was
like yeah i'm a league player yeah yeah
i'm a league player throughout he's just
telling me all this more about all the
kdp
because i remember i was actually uh
because kda debuted at the 2018.
i think you'd love to tell everyone you
were there yeah yeah no no no because i
won't [ __ ] stop telling people that
he was there when kda premiered yeah no
because people ask me because whenever i
whenever whenever i meet something
people ask me did you work at the bbc
and were you with the lawyers
whenever whenever i meet a fellow league
fan i'm just like oh yeah i was at the
2018 uh world war ii and i [ __ ]
rolled my eyes when i
then and then people asked oh how was it
and i was like oh kda was great and then
they ask oh how's the match i'm just
like oh kda was great
because i can't remember anything else
because that was the only highlight
yeah yeah we we didn't just get like we
did we didn't just lose got [ __ ]
obliterated okay so kenny a well kda
though that's all that matters kda was
great and that's what matters that's
that was that was worth the ticket cost
of flying all the way to [ __ ] korea
korea was great i want to go back to
korea
league worlds may have ended but the
real [ __ ] was the arcane anime
end of league worlds i sleep arcane real
[ __ ]
bro please jay please i'm begging you
just give it a walk i'll watch you no
please actually like i've never wanted
something more in my life i will
absolutely watch it well there's a fan
i'd give you the permission to watch our
kids
i said i'll give you
yeah honestly honestly uh if if there
are any
viewers watching this who are not a fan
of league even if you hate league please
watch arcane you know if if it continues
to get even better than it is right now
which i i would be impressed if it does
yeah genuinely it was going to be like a
[ __ ] hood class i want to be
surprised though it's going to be a
certified hood classic i wouldn't be
surprised though because like every as
you said like everything that they've
released that's not the game has been
amazing like even for people who don't
give a [ __ ] i don't understand what's
going on i don't understand why riot
still pretends to be a gaming company
it's generally because i would well
right multimedia company yeah okay if
they nail this right league his show
okay so that league in the law
has so many different like actions and
uh like i guess eras yeah yeah different
areas that completely have characters
they don't even ever interact with each
other and they're focusing on a certain
area now that has certain characters
like if this kicks it out the park i'm
just excited for the opportunities of
like we could get the league universe
yeah yeah yeah the lcu
i'll be i'll be [ __ ] down for the lcu
bro because there's like there's like in
legal there was like i don't know
anything about it but i know there's
like a great war yeah yeah software that
was like that could be [ __ ] hype bro
like it's the first
like like to arcane has made me care
about league law like after i watched
arcane i i started reading [ __ ] wiki
articles to be like yo
joey it's what else can we explore yeah
it's such an such an interesting world
and there's so many opportunities for
just like different elements to clash
together because there are some league
like right now we're focusing on like
human characters in like a city you know
but there are like there are other
cities other civilization and then there
there are just like [ __ ] gods in the
league law as well yeah there's like
which other characters yeah which i'm
thinking if they can like
integrate that somehow then it is
literally just the mcu all over again
right
yeah yeah i i could just see it there's
just like the [ __ ] like you know how
like uh spoilers for end game i guess
you know how like captain america just
gets his hammer they could be [ __ ] like
that i guess just like i don't know
zack turns into a blob i guess
there's just like there's some random
ass characters as well that i would love
to see how they would integrate there's
a character in league right called tom
kenz right his whole story this
character is that he's just a massive
what is he a frog or some [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is tam ken i think he's a frog a
massive frog-esque thing yeah he just
lives in a swamp that eats humans and i
just love and he has no connection to
like any other characters ever like pike
i think it's just like how would you how
would you include a character that just
eats people like that how would you do
that i'd love to see it but it's amazing
because the best thing about this
character is that he speaks in like a
really thick southern drawl right right
so it's just like a small guy it's like
it's just like
i don't even know what some of his lines
are he's like this is my swarm
i don't know he's just like i'll give
you a daughter or something like that i
don't know it's like really interesting
i don't know i'd love to see how they
integrate these weird-ass characters in
the league
i don't know i don't know how it is for
the viewers just seeing joey pretend
like try his hardest to like care
and explains arrow games to me i think
it's okay for me to sit here and explain
legal or
look look forward to my in-depth review
for next week's episode which is
definitely coming legitimately if you
watch it i think you will actually enjoy
it okay like legitimately he'll come
back and he'll be like guys i've made a
mistake
we're just gonna keep talking about it
until like he'll just have to like
buckle one day i'm gonna read one piece
and he's gonna watch this
[Music]
yeah okay
sure this is easy to watch you get a
treat watching this i have to slog
through one piece
but like yeah i legitimately think think
it is one of the best things i've
watched this year like anime or not like
i i can't even think of how many things
i've just i'm not sure if that's telling
of this year's content or not we've
actually had some pretty good stuff
we've got some good stuff this year i i
don't know because i'm trying i know